so hello everybody in a few days I've
got a major video coming it's going to
be a video of an event I did with Jordan
Peterson in November in which I talk
about sacred art but I try to talk about
it in secular terms and so giving
secular arguments for sacred art I even
quote Camille Paglia as my main source
for how secular thinking secular
thinkers are considering sacred art as
the the root or the frame out of which
culture flows and so I'm looking forward
to that but in the meantime I've been
thinking a lot in the past few weeks you
know people on have been really amazing
at supporting me on patreon and I'm
trying to figure out ways to encourage
people that have been supporting me to
thank them to to help them understand
that I really appreciate the time that
it's opening up for me to do this and so
one of the things I'm thinking of doing
is that when I reach two thousand
dollars a month on patreon I'm going to
add one more talk a month for patreon
subscribers and what I'm going to do is
I'm still going to keep the two the two
talks the two videos a month for free
for anybody who wants to see them so
there'll be a movie interpretation or
cultural interpretation every month and
one that's going to be dealing more with
Christian symbolism in particular and so
I thought that I would add one more
video a month which would look at
traditional stories folk stories and so
what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna do I'm
gonna make the first video here for
everyone on YouTube and for all of you
who were supporting me on patreon tell
me what you think if you think it's a
good idea and if you think that it's
something that's valuable for you in the
future and so what I want to talk about
is a story that a lot of people maybe
find a bit strange and it's the story of
Puss in Boots the story of the cat who
wears boots I remember when I was a
child that was I was fascinated by this
story but at the same time it seemed so
strange and so absurd that it was
difficult to understand and as I started
to understand symbolism I saw that in
fact the
puss-in-boots story was a very a very
very powerful structure and it's a very
powerful structure that's helpful for us
right now if you followed some of my
videos the videos where I talk about the
how world gets turned back on its feet
how when something is chaotic and upside
down how it can it can come back up out
of the water let's say well the story of
Puss in Boots gives us a great example
and so I'm going to go through the story
and I'm going to show you how it
compares to other traditional stories
and hopefully we can pull out of it
a let's say an understanding of how the
end of something can become a new
beginning
[Music]
this is Jonathan Petro
welcome to the symbolic world
[Applause]
the story of the story of Puss in Boots
is rather simple the eye a Miller dies
and he has three sons he leaves to his
oldest son he leaves his mill to his
second son he leaves his donkey hores or
his ass and to his youngest son
he leaves his cat and so obviously if
you look at the structure in terms of
existing in the world in terms of
production the two first sons get
something which can help them to to
exist in the world so the the the
obviously the mill will help the oldest
son become a Miller himself the second
son with a donkey can maybe plow a field
can become a a farmer but the third son
gets a cat and so the idea of a an
animal which doesn't have a function
which is just there to provide company
is important to understand in the sense
that we're moving from meaning from
order into let's say the absurd or
rather the the per the recreational
let's say okay so the animal is there
doesn't have a function in in productive
society and so the youngest son gets the
the cat and so what is there's nothing
he can do with the cat and so the
youngest son is he sad he's despondent
and she's wondering what am I gonna do
and all of a sudden this cat starts to
speak to him and he says my master if
you get for me a pair of boots and a bag
then you know I will find your fortune
or I'll help you out and so the Miller
is extremely similar son is extremely
surprised to see this but he he bets on
this right so he takes his last amount
of money or whatever he spends his last
little amount that he has and he buys
boots for this cat now the cat goes out
and with the bag he's able to catch a I
think it's a either a rabbit or some
birds and he brings those to the King
presents him as a gift and
as a gift of the Marquis de Carabas like
a know of a nobleman who gave gives
these these animals to the king and the
king is extremely happy and in the story
usually he does it a few times does it
usually twice and the second he the
second time it brings it again and he's
like you know this is a gift from the
Marquis de cada bar and the king is
impressed
who is this must be the Kaaba you know
what's going on so while the cat is in
the castle he finds out that the king
and the princess are going to go out on
a stroll they're gonna go out for a
stroll in in a carriage and so he
quickly goes out tells his master okay
take all your clothes off get into the
water and then when the the the king and
the the quid the princess comes by I'm
going to come and say that you know he
probably doesn't know he doesn't tell
him what to do just I take the cola get
into the water it's even better and so
the the the Miller son takes coal dog
gets into the water and he said just
just stay there you know and don't and
don't and so when the Kings arrives he
the the cats are screaming you know my
master my master he's out in the water
he's going to drown he was attacked by
some thieves and they took his clothes
and now he he can't come out and you
know he paints this dramatic picture of
a situation where the the Marquis de
Carabas you know lost his clothes and
now is naked there in the water and he
can't come out and so he's in trouble so
the King tells his servants to give to
the the Marquis de Carabas some new
clothes obviously to help him and that
the king of course because the Marquis
has been so generous in the past and
because he was so impressed by by the
gifts that he brought him he's going to
to take the Mackay back to his castle
and so the king takes him out puts on
these new clothes for the the the the
young Miller son and he puts on clothes
that make him look like he's noble now
remember that because that's important
when we interpret it and the son gets
into the key to the carriage as they're
moving towards the the miller's castle
he doesn't have a castle obviously the
cat
in advance and he sees these people you
know plowing a field and he tells people
plowing a field if the king comes by and
ask you to who belongs this field you
tell them that it belongs to the Marquis
de Carabas or else you're gonna get a
serious beating you know you're gonna be
in trouble and then he key goes on and
he finds usually it's something else
like a beautiful forest grove and there
there are our peasants there and he
tells the peasants the same thing and as
the king is coming by you know he comes
by this beautiful field he's like wow
what a beautiful land with a beautiful
field who does this belong to and the
answer of course is this belonged to the
Marquis de Catawba several times in a
row and the king is starting to think
wow this Marquis is impressive you know
he's quite something to have all this
beautiful land and so as the
puss-in-boots continues he gets to the
castle and in the castle is a giant ogre
it's a monster and the monster is is a
owns this castle so the cat knocks on
the door the ogre answers and is
impressive and very scary he's like what
do you want what are you doing here and
the cats as well I've heard that you are
an extremely powerful ogre and you have
you have amazing magical powers and so
I've come here to to see you know this
you know if you really live up to this
amazing reputation that you have and the
ogre is like he's a bit flattered but
just want to show it so the cat comes in
and he says is it true that you're able
to transform yourself and anything that
you want and the ogre says yeah of
course and he changes himself into a
lion and now you know the cat is afraid
and kind of moves away and the ogre is
happy because he scared the cat and and
the cat says oh that's very impressive
but it would be way more impressive if
you could transform yourself in
something that is really small because
you're so huge imagined she could
transform yourself in something tiny
like a mouse let's say so the ogre
transforms himself into a mouse and then
the cat eats the mouse and so as the
king is coming up in his carriage the
cat runs out and he says your are your
highness welcome welcome
to the castle
of the Marquis de Carabas and that
Marquis comes in and the king is so
impressed by the by the Marquis and by
everything that's there that he gives to
the Marquis he gives to the Miller son
his daughter in marriage and by now the
Miller is legitimately let's say as much
as you can imagine has become the owner
of a castle the owner of these fields
because the fields happen to belong to
the ogre actually so he owns the field
he owns the castle and he now has
married the princess and so one of the
things that people think in terms of
fairytales especially in terms of the
the more modern let's say the more
modern era of fairy tales is they tend
to think that fairy tales are there to
give a moral lesson and that's not
actually the case
and in this story and there's a few
stories like this like for example the
story of Jack and the Beanstalk where
you really struggle to find in the story
a kind of simple more morality tale
where you know if you're good and you're
honest and you're nice and all these
things and you'll get what it is what
the store is actually discussing is how
the world flips how the lowest thing can
become the highest thing how one world
ends and another world begins okay and
so I'm going to tell you a little little
bit of another story and you'll see how
it's related now you have to think of
the story of Noah and the Ark okay now
in the story of Noah and the art the
world is getting worse and worse and
worse and the way it's getting worse is
through this increase in artificial
things like the increase of of
civilization the increase of society but
also the increase of kind of
entertainments are you in the genealogy
of Adam you you hear talk about no
cities and then take
ecology and then music and finally the
development of iron and iron weapons and
the world is getting more and more
corrupt because the world is being
changed but also you know these these
technically the the world is living more
and more in it in in its margin let's
say if you imagine a person like the
heart then as you move out of the heart
then you add these layers of clothing
and tools and civilization and
everything and it makes the world more
fragile and it also leads us out into
our into our passions let's say into
these these strange obsessions anybody
who who thinks about the internet will
understand how that works quite easily
and so the world is kind of coming down
down down down down now God says to Noah
build an ark and it's really important
people miss this detail in the story is
that what we've seen is the world become
more and more technical but then God
tells Noah to build an ark that is to
use technical means to create something
by which now you will be able to survive
the end of this world now another thing
that also happens in the story is that
there's these mixtures of the sons of
God and the daughters of men it doesn't
matter how you interpret it some
interpreted as angels and men some
interpreted as let's say a higher that's
a higher more noble people that kind of
mix them and and and and mix with like a
more decadent types of people and that
created all kinds of chaos but Noah
himself
there are several traditions which says
that Noah married namah namah is part of
the lineage of Cain and so Noah also did
you know it that's not in the Bible but
it the reason why it's in the tradition
is to help us understand how Noah is an
ambiguous figure himself that he follows
God but he's also a product of all of
this increase in technology but also
this increase in mixture and then he's
the one who builds the art and then puts
all these animals in a boat and then
crosses over to the other side and in
that story before he crosses over to the
other side the world is filled with
these giants okay so you have think of
the terms of the Noah story you have a
world that's coming down you have giants
that that are kind of causing this bad
thing to happen
you also have animals and you have this
ambiguous figure which is able to cross
over and then take on the other side
start the world again let's say okay um
and so in the in the story of Puss in
Boots you can see the same terms let me
tell you another story to help you kind
of see the pattern once you see the
pattern it'll help you to understand
what this can mean now there's I've told
you the story before and other talks but
it's the story of st. Christopher
now st. Christopher is a giant in some
traditions he's also a hybrid in other
tradition he's a mixture of you know
he's like a dog man a man with a head of
a dog and so he's a ambiguous figure and
Saint Christopher he he's he's a he's a
monster he can't really do the things
properly and so because he's not able to
pray he's not able to he's not able to
pray he's not able to fast he's not able
to do all these things he stands on the
side of the river and he crosses people
over okay and now the child the Christ
child comes to st. Christopher and he
tells Saint Christopher that carry me to
the other side so st. Christopher
carries him to the other side but as
he's crossing over there's this immense
weight and you know he can't hold
himself and he's sinking into the water
as the child is on his shoulders but he
doesn't understand why and once he
reaches the other side this the child
tells them the Saint Christopher asked
him like why was it so heavy why were it
why was it almost impossible for me to
cross you over and the the child tells
him because I was carrying
the sins of the world on my shoulders
and so what has happened is that Christ
has actually tricked Saint Christopher
into becoming a vehicle for himself
becoming a vehicle for crossing the the
the waters of chaos and re-emerging on
the other side okay now here's another
story a a princess you've heard me tell
this story quite a few times a princess
has a golden ball she loses it in the
water a frog who talks right we have a
cat that talks now we have a frog that
talks we also have a dog headed man that
talks so the Frog that talks tells her
I'll get the ball
if you accept to take me into the castle
to give me some of some of your food and
also to let me sleep in your bed and so
the princess accepts and then the Frog
goes to the sadness of the princess who
doesn't want to do it she's forced to do
it because she's promised and in a way
this frog tricks the princess into
loving him she doesn't really love him
but it's like this weird artifice that
he sets up and in some story she
actually kills the Frog she throws the
Frog against the wall and then after
after all of that has happened this kind
of weird inversion and trick then he
turns into a prince and they get married
until you have this talking animal you
have water you have this crossing of the
water and you have it happening in terms
of trick in terms of this in this kind
of this inverted thing that happens okay
now that's the story of Puss in Boots is
exactly the same you have a talking cat
and the talking cat is
to take the the loser of the story who
is the the prince who is not a prince
yet the son of the Miller who doesn't
have anything all he has is this cat and
so he by giving him these boots the fact
that the cat wears boots is important
because it has to create the confusion
between a person and an animal there has
to be this ambiguous figure right there
that helps you cross over the waters
okay and so by making the cat speak and
making the cat wear clothing because
obviously only human beings naturally
wear clothing by making him wear
clothing he is able were able to create
this ambiguous figure and this ambiguous
figure this trickster this gesture is
able to turn things back and bring them
back so that what is below what is on
bot when the bottom now comes to the top
now you've heard me talk about this
quite before the role of the jesters at
the end of a cycle the role I've talked
about it in the talk I gave with Jordan
Peterson in Vancouver less I'll put
links to that in the video so if you
haven't seen that you can see it but
this idea that the the there's a that
the that at the end there's some kind of
trick which brings us brings us to the
next world and so the the the cat uses
this trick and and the Miller son
himself is actually innocent of all of
this okay
the Millers son is not complicit in the
trick and so the fact that the the
Millers son benefits from the trick he
remains innocent across the story it's
actually the cat who's operating these
tricks you know below him let's say so
that the Miller son can cross over the
water so that the just can-can can now
attain what in in the end would be the
idea that the Miller son was actually
always the prince at say in his heart
was always you know in his being was
always that's always what it was
but there needed to be a crossing over
for him to become that um and so you can
see that he he tricks but he also he
also kills the giant by tricking him and
so you can see the you can in the
stories you'll always see there's a a
giant type figure and a hybrid type
figure and those can sometime
interchange but they're they they'll be
facing each other so a place where you
have these two kind of giant and let's
say hybrid figures facing each other
that's across from the river there's one
one version that can help you see it but
where it actually doesn't succeed where
the crossing over and the flip that I'm
talking about doesn't succeed is in the
story of Hercules in essence so Nasus is
a center which stands on the side of the
river and Hercules comes and asks necess
to cross his wife over to the other side
and so here's this hybrid horse man
figure who goes to cross the Hercules
wipe to the other side but then he's
going to steal her from him and take her
for himself and sometimes either he
clubs
Nasus or he shoots an arrow and he kills
necess and the idea is that Hercules is
able to kill ness as before the before
the whole thing flips over let's say and
then nessus takes Hercules white but you
can see the terms kind of play each
other out this idea of of this crossing
over the river and how there's a trick
that happens inside the river or related
to the river another amazing version of
this is in the three Billy Goats Gruff
where the three Billy Goats are crossing
a river to go to the other side and
there is a a has a monster on under the
bridge a troll under the bridge and the
troll asks goes to eat the first billy
goat and the billy goat says I'm too
small I'm too small don't eat me and the
second billy goat says I'm too small and
too small don't eat me and then the
third billy goat who's the biggest billy
goat now the troll is saying okay this
is the biggest billy goat i'm going to
eat him but it's actually a trick
because now the billy goat is
big that the Billy Goat is able to kill
the troll and then all three have
crossed over to the other side okay
and so you can see how the story of
puss-in-boots
follows that exact pattern and what the
pattern is is that as we reach the edge
of something as we reach the end of a
world of a civilization of of anything
what happens there is there's a
trick there's something there's a flip
that happens and then that flip is a
surprise and then what comes out is this
new world and the ultimate version of
this is in the story of Christ now when
there's a a tradition about Christ which
takes the story of Christ it kind of
expands it it it's called the gospel of
nicodemus and a lot of these traditions
from the gospel of nicodemus were
probably there in the church before and
and were taken up by the church in
different forms you know in different
imagery different iconography and it's
this idea of the descent into Hades and
so in the story of the descent into
Hades Christ dies and then he descends
into death and now in death you have
these these characters of Hades and the
devil who are cheering because they've
taken you know the the the light of the
world into darkness but then it ends up
being a trick because if you take light
into darkness obviously its darkness it
disappears and so the and so the death
of Christ actually becomes the manner in
which the world starts again because of
that inversion which happens at the at
the bottom in the darkness and so this
is just to kind of show you the the the
pattern and and and it would be
interesting for people to think about it
think about other stories that you know
that have this this pattern of a
crossing of the water and how there is a
an ambiguous aspect of it which carries
let's say and ambiguous aspect is death
of course it's an image of death now the
story of Christ it's actually death
itself but in other stories it can be
these ambiguous figures like christen
boots like like Nessus it can also be
for example in the story of Elijah who
crosses the river
it can be a garment of skin a garment of
dead animal skins which help him cross
over any and it all could be an ark full
of animals this whole idea of flesh and
animal and death all these images that
are kind of the support for the the pure
thing or the highest thing to then cross
over and start the world anew so that
gives you a little bit of an idea of how
these these patterns work and how these
structures work how they work through
different stories and so yeah so I'm
looking forward to reading your comments
and your questions if you have any I'm
doing these more improvisational style
and so sometimes I might be missing a
few details and so make sure you remind
me if I do and so in the next few days
I'm going to post a major video and so
yeah looking forward to hearing from all
of you alright bye bye if you enjoyed
this content and our exploration of
symbolism get involved I love to read
your comments in the comment section
below please go ahead and share this on
social media to all your friends and
also please consider supporting us
financially on patreon you'll find a
link to the patreon page in the
description below